for the european union strengthening and  energizing its partnership with india is  a priority in this upcoming decade  both our regions are driving forces in  the digital revolution  and as like-minded partners the european  union and india will be working on  several tracks we have launch  negotiations  free trade agreement as well as on  investment protection and geographical  indications for europe  this is a strategic investment in our  partnership with india  india and the european union are closely  aligned in the fight against climate  change and of course have understood  how precious solar energies  both  india and the european union have  embarked on their way to net zero we are  the two largest democracies in the world  and together we have a lot to give for  the benefit of the people